the prophet Muhammad s. wasallam told us
whoever builds a mosque for Allah Allah
will build for him a similar house in
Jen and we know the great reward that
will not only be gained but rather will
fill your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives shahada in the Masid
whenever someone learns something in the
Masid yes that will be something that
you'll have on your
scale
there is no evidence that having sex
with a lot of women translates into an
ability to understand women in the
context of a committed relationship or
or longevous relationship there is no
evidence of that so in for for this is
where the red pill makes a lot of claims
assertions but they're not backed
because the idea is I feel like there's
just ad hoc justifications and
rationalization for heathenism
which is effectively just doing whatever
you want whatever you desire but really
let's let's let us um assess this claim
the claim that if you have sex with a
lot of women that that's going to lead
to you knowing women more and therefore
having a stronger relationship more
longevous relationship with some kind of
woman but there's no it doesn't seem to
me that there's any evidence to that
affect because I I was looking at some
studies on casual sex yeah and I was
looking at there's like five or six of
them that have been done and all of
those studies there first first of all
they're mixed they're contradictory
funny enough some of them say that yeah
they harm women actually most of them
say they harm women casual sex harm
women that that is a consensus
psychological finding it harms men too A
lot of these studies but it some of them
say it harms men some some of them say
it doesn't harm men but there's no study
that says it helps them in relationships
do you know what I mean of yeah of
course not and they would never run a
study like that because it would be
considered unethical right and we know
that you know when they run these
studies they have to be politically
correct they got to get funding they
have to do it in a certain way to get
the blessing with what will say is um uh
with the whole body sleeping with women
or whatever it may be it's not
necessarily to understand women better
it's to understand the women that you
don't want to necessarily be with and I
think that's half the game because what
ends up happening right in a remember I
mean you're you're in the UK so you know
this too I mean the UK is going through
this as well we live in a very
hypersexualized world where women are
more promiscuous than ever before so my
thing is right I look at it like and I
was just having discussion with Andrew
he's a devout Orthodox Christian and he
saw my perspective on this too if you're
going to meet try to meet a woman in the
west where they are uh promiscuous they
don't necessarily adhere to gender roles
when it doesn't benefit them they want a
man that makes money but they don't want
to necessarily submit Etc I think it's
very important for you as a man to
identify these women early on and not
bring them into your life because the
the beauty of religion right whether
it's
Christianity Islam or Judaism is that it
basically had an institution of Shame
and it had what I call training wheels
to keep women honest with their man you
know it pretty much shamed them for not
doing things that they were supposed to
do but these Training Wheels Are
effectively gone we live in a secular
world now um and unless you're a very
religious man and you're meeting a very
religious woman it's going to be very
difficult for you to find a woman that's
virtuous so my thing is I think if you
know and the other reason why I think
this is so important is because um when
you get married right luckily you know
in the in Islam you can just go to a go
to a mosque go to anom he'll marry you
boom done you don't got to worry about
the state being involved but most people
don't get married that way they get
married through the state and with with
the way the family courts are set up
with the way divorce is set up with the
way it's basically an entire industry
against men I look at it like if you're
going to go ahead and you want to have a
family one day which is the nuclear
family which is the backbone of society
um and you want to get married you are
taking on a tremendous amount of risk
and I don't want you to go in blind
however if you're getting married and
the state isn't involved and um there's
no severe consequences to you
financially um then sure go ahead and be
sa less sexual experience of me a woman
because at least you're not going to be
severely punished for it but my thing is
the reason why I even gave that idea
like hey get with more women so that you
understand them is because I just don't
want men to deal with the the whors of
the family court now is it the best
solution probably not but I think it's a
pragmatic one given the the world that
we're now so what here's the thing I
just want to know what the evidence is
so of for example having intercourse
with multiple women what benefit like
let's say 50 or 30 what what benefit are
you alleging that it has on the man what
benefit are you alleging it that's a
that's a fair question every man has
different competence right so like one
some one guy might be able to hook up
with 10 girls and be like okay you know
what I get it like I've I I don't you
know it is what it is but another guy
you know might be incompetent might be
an idiot every everyone's you know level
of adaptation is different so I'm not
saying oh have a heart 50 and don't get
married it's like no if you find a girl
that's worthy that's fine um and I would
argue that like our podcast is like
we're able to kind of fast line it where
you know remember this information
hasn't been out for very long so people
are kind of learning now through us
talking about it on our platform Etc so
they might not necessarily have to even
hit 50 because they're learning from our
mistakes you know the Chinese but what
if they do get 50 what's what's the
benefit of that what do they get from
that well hopefully depending on the
individual they are able to identify
women that are worthy versus ones that
aren't in in a sexual
capacity well I'm also assuming that
this person would be seeing this woman
if they're just looking to have then
obviously it's just going to it's going
to be a waste but I'm talking about uh
you know you're obviously courting this
woman you're hanging out with this woman
Etc you're seeing her look my my friend
had your book uh I was trying to look
for it myself it's called oh
nice I was trying to find something and
and actually I was flicking through it
right before I spoke to you and I like
the like you know the uh the the
statistics you have on here one of them
that you had on here was uh for example
that a man will will spend 30 hours or
something like this this doing 30 hours
doing um speed dating online in order to
just get one date 1.46 date in a in a in
the year or something like that now what
I'm saying is that to get 50 women look
you know it's a numbers game and I know
it's a numbers game yeah the feasibility
the amount of man hours that you're
going to need to put in to have
intercourse with 50 women that are not
prostitutes according to your statistics
that you mention right the amount of man
hours we're talking about like if he's
going to use Tinder or some kind of an
app and according to to these stats he's
going to need to do a lot of that right
and the and the question of benefit here
is an important one obviously from a
religious
standpoint Muslims Christians and Jews
all agree that sex shouldn't even be
done outside of marriage now it is still
possible to marry 50 women I mean I'm
not saying you cannot marry and divorce
50 women it's a possibility but I'm not
necessarily
saying um that one should do that of
course we wouldn't agree with that one
one should do that the point I'm trying
to get at is that there isn't actually
any good evidence that having
intercourse with that many women would
make would give you a kind of benefit in
the relationship in fact you could you
could argue for the opposite because if
you if if you get sex very easily going
back to the idea of uh virtue then you
can be less restrained in your sexual
appetites and this is something that in
virtue ethics is referred to as
Temperance so if you're less restrained
you don't have as much um you don't have
as much restraint for example you don't
have self-control and if you don't have
willpower and self control in one area
you're less likely to have it in other
areas and I've read that in a book
called willpower funny enough by Roy Bas
very fantastic book I recommend it but
he mentioned the point that if you have
willpower in one area for example he
mentioned fasting religious fasting as
an example Roy B Meister uh if you have
willpower and discipline in one area
it's transferable to other areas the
idea of getting 50 women having sex with
them which is difficult anyway according
to these stats because just cuz you're
dating a woman it doesn't mean you're
going to have sex with her as you know
like for the average person you guys not
might not be the average person because
you know from a stateus perspective you
guys have got you know big Channel good
money coming in the guy's wearing a nice
Rolex red face I like it fresh uh and
you're wearing a nice watch as well you
know you guys are well put together
thank you bro thank you bro so not
everyone is fresh and not everyone's
myON gains and so it's not going to be
easy to get sex like that so for them to
put 30 hours 50 hours to get one a date
and then after that to get like a
hundred of those maybe 30 I don't know
how many what the numbers would be a
conversion rate Five dates to one woman
having sex maybe I don't know is that my
you know more about keep in mind keep in
mind right because people tend to um
criticize my uh you know my idea that
you should have sex with 50 women but
there's a bunch of other things I tell
guys to have in place as well they
should make a certain amount of money 35
years old be in shape um they need to
have a bunch of things in line so that
they can be in a position and the reason
why I said say this like so here's it
here this is what it is yeah make 100
six figures a year or more have six
months or a year of savings be in shape
um 50 women and then be 35 years old the
reason why I say have these five things
in place is because most women right
will look at you as a higher status more
attractive male which in will inevitably
put her and her feminine put you in your
masculine so the relationship ends up uh
actually working because we all know
what happens when you deal with a
rambunctious woman now I mean if a
person reaches 10 bodies 20 bodies 30 40
um and he has other things in place oh
no sorry baby I can't commit to you
because I I need to hit 50 no and like I
said before with our podcast we might be
able to curve it where they don't need
to necessarily hit that number but I'm
speaking from a general perspective for
most people and then also with the as
far as the book goes with the uh the
dating stuff um this is why I'm such a
big proponent of not relying on online
dating I tell people meet people me
girls through your friends meet girls
when you're out uh meet them out in real
life use Instagram we have multiple
different um ways that you need to go
ahead and Source women now with that
said of course if you're religious then
this might not necessarily apply to you
because you're um you're going against
your religious beliefs but my thing is
this if you're a religious guy right and
you can't do this that's totally fine
the only thing I ask is I want them to
make sure that they don't get married
with the state you don't need to hit
this body count number if you're getting
married and it's just religious strictly
no I see I see look a lot of what you
said there a lot of what you said there
is very reasonable I don't think it's
wrong for a man to Aspire uh to to make
a certain money like a certain uh amount
of money I don't think it's wrong for
them to put themselves in the I think
it's actually quite praiseworthy frankly
you know there's nothing wrong with that
my only issue is that the reason why I
mentioned the 50 body count thing is
because I this is my analysis bro and
you can tell me what you think we're
living in a a Time historians refer to
as Pax Americana yeah it's a time where
America is a superpower and as a result
Western countries have not had to have
wars where they themselves are in danger
in the ways that they had in the past
okay it's more like incursions or
invasions or whatever it may be as a
result we in the west are living in a
state of relative ease and comfort
Arthur schopenhauer a famous philosopher
he said that uh human beings of
humankind mankind vacillates
between uh extreme boredom and extreme
fear okay I think now we're living in an
age of extreme boredom because we're not
fearing that someone's going to kill us
yeah in in a war context as a result we
are missing what most cultures in the
past refer to as rights of Passage for
men this is where the masculinity crisis
comes in because before a man could
prove that he is a man by stepping on
the battlefield now that that kind of um
opportunity is no longer afforded to us
on the same kind of level and as a
result we have invented rights of
Passage for men so that they can feel
like they have gone through a certain
process and now they're men
and what I see with the red pill
movement is that they've invented
arbitrary and ad hoc rights of Passage
which actually feed more into hedonistic
liberal thinking than anything else
which they're scanty to no evidence that
will improve them as an individual
virtuously or otherwise the like of
which we've just mentioned the 50 body
count thing which I know comes from the
rational male because that was the first
place I read I don't know if you got it
from there as well so the point is is he
just calls it play Theory um yeah I mean
what I'm saying to you is in the the
time it would take you to find non
prostitutes that are 50 in number that
you can have sex with in the west you
can spend making money for yourself you
can spend working on yourself you can
you can spend improving your bravery you
improving your your proficiency your
strength cuz the thing is I feel like
there's an underlying assumption with
the red pill movement yeah and the
Assumption almost is is that we should
live our lives to make ourselves most
marketable for women
allb